Oh thank you
just lost my contact lens hope you find
it electrical problems in the
building always the same isn't it
are we back on the fifth floor yes the fifth, my friend claire
lives here i'm visiting her she's expecting me
what's going on
I can't tell the difference
between my waking life and dreams day and
night it must be very difficult the voice
this chaos
embrace it
Welcome back everyone marvel just dropped a brand
new moon knight trailer and clip so we'll break it
all down there's a bunch of easter eggs and moon
knight episodes are starting in a couple weeks
i'll be doing videos for all them so be sure to
subscribe to get them i'm doing the giveaway for
disney plus memberships again all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just post all your
theories about what's going to happen during the
series the clip that they start with is kind of
like a moon knight versus khonshu kind of scene
except it's stephen grant versus khonshu and this
seems like it's happening during the events of
episode one before steven grant has learned who
marc spector is that he's really marc spector
and steven grant is just an alternate persona
and what we're witnessing is kanchu coming to try
and talk to marc spector to give him orders to
tell him to do things as moon knight you're my
avatar on earth you're supposed to be the fist
of kanchu you're supposed to do what i say but
because of the way that marvel is portraying his
multiple personalities on the show initially this
alternate persona that he creates steven grant
does not know about the origin story he doesn't
know he went to egypt he doesn't know that he
made this pact with khonshu so he's just seeing
this giant bird skeleton coming for him and
freaking out the old lady really is an old lady
this isn't just happening inside his head the
scene is actually happening inside the apartment
building that we see in all the trailers where
he's waking up in bed as steven grant in that
black shirt not really sure what's going on but
he's starting to see things like he's starting to
see conscious appear all over the place trying to
talk to him and he just thinks that he's going
crazy he doesn't know anything about khonshu or
marc spector so he's just treating this like he's
inside a horror movie if you weren't a marvel fan
you didn't know who kanchu was and you saw a giant
bird skeleton coming for you you would probably
run like this too there are a couple easter eggs
inside the elevator that runs into now there's a
lot of graffiti in the background that's really
hard to make out usually graffiti winds up being
some kind of easter egg like names of production
crew members but you see these two different
stickers over on the wall here like there's
ice cream in the flower those are just meant to
represent the two different personas that it seems
like they're using on the show at least initially
in the more recent marvel comics he's had as many
as four different personalities so we'll see how
many they wind up going with by the end of the
series right now they're just showing us the moon
knight marc spector personality in the stephen
grand personality they're treating the trailer
as if when he's in full moon eye gear like when
he armors up he is in his marc spector personality
the last trailer that they released has a
bunch of scenes with marc spector speaking to
steven grant inside their head their mutual
head steven grant starts to find all of marc
spector's gear his passport his weapons then his
original marc spector personality surfaces and
says steven you weren't supposed to find all this
this might be a little bit different for the mcu
version of moon knight but in the comics the whole
reason why he created the different personalities
is because right after he became moon knight
and came back to the united states to actually
use his powers for good he figured that he would
need a couple different personalities in order
to be an effective vigilante so he created the
stephen grant millionaire playboy persona which
is a bit like batman creating the bruce wayne
persona like batman is the true personality
marc spector moon knight is meant to be the
true personality of moon knight he creates the
millionaire playboy steven graham persona just
that he's able to hobnob and it explains why he
has so much text so much gear where it all comes
from oh he's rich that's how he has all these toys
he creates the jake lockley cab driver persona and
that's sort of like his version of matches malone
to make another batman reference like batman used
matches malone to get information from mob members
because normally people would try to lie to batman
or to bruce wayne it's the same situation for moon
knight but as far as we know they're not doing
the jake lockley persona on the tv show that
might be a little bit different they might show us
later in the series that there is a jake lockley
in there somewhere when he's in the white suit
that is the mr knight persona that's relatively
recent that's sort of like the world's greatest
detective moon knight persona but on the tv show
they might just be saying that this is still marc
spectre moon knight and say that he's in the same
personality when he's wearing the suit as when
he's wearing the full blown superhero costume
what they explain though is that over time
marc spector had been switching between the
different personas so much that he actually
developed full-blown dissociative identity
disorder and had trouble distinguishing
in who the real personality was but the
mcu explainer is going to be a little bit
different i'm assuming that the trauma of his
supposed death and then resurrection at the
hands of khonshu will be one of the reasons
why he thinks that he's stephen grant and that'll
be the cause of his mind fracturing in this way
i think part of the idea that marc spector being
former cia being this mercenary character he
already has several different identities that
he's been using as aliases in his activities
as a mercenary around the world so he may have
already created the steven grant alias before
he became moon knight my assumption right now is
that they just simplified things and they're only
doing a couple of the personalities they're not
doing like every single comic book personality
because most of the people watching this tv show
like the millions of people that will watch it
have not read the moonlight comics they don't want
to make it too complicated it looks like they're
also taking a little bit of inspiration from some
of the more recent moon knight runs i think it was
moon knight vol 8 when he just shows up in this
mysterious mental hospital and he can't remember
who the true personality is like he forgets
that he was originally marc spector in the
stephen grant persona jake lockley are meant to
be alternate personas he also starts to think that
moon knight was a real person who created marc
spector instead of it being the other way around
and even though kanchu is a fairly antagonistic
god he does try to help marc spector at different
times and he does try to help keep this cosmic
balance like there are bigger cosmic problems that
kanchow gets involved in because he is a legit
god so he's not necessarily a good character but
he's not evil either but at least the beginning
of the series in episode one before they fully
reveal the backstory and how he became moonlight
the way they're portraying khonshu makes him seem
fairly antagonistic in that same comic where he
winds up in the mental hospital and forgets which
the original personality was and who created who
inside his head they teased the idea that kanchu
is the one that put him in the mental hospital
because he wants marc spector to break so that
khonshu can physically take over his body and
physically enter the main mcu dimension conscious
and his pantheon of gods are actually trapped in
this alternate dimension called the other void
it looks like this is a scene here where kancho
is explaining that to marc spector like the
whiter cosmos the whiter cosmic history of the mcu
this is the truth of reality so the only way that
khonshu can get involved in the affairs of the
main mcu dimension is to work through an avatar
like marc spector it's a little bit like dormammu
not being able to enter the main mcu dimension
initially and having to work through kaiselius and
his other followers so when marc spector is dying
at the footsteps of his statue in the desert the
special temple khonshu sees that as an opportunity
one of khonshu's powers that they don't totally
get into in any of this trailer footage is that
he does gain a measure of immortality through his
connection to kanchu but it's not immortality the
way you would think about it he can still take
damage he can still be killed issues that every
time he does die khonshu brings him back from the
dead so he resurrects marc spector moon knight
it's a bit like johnny blaze ghost rider like
he legit died and he only is alive again because
of the bargain that he made with mephisto so i am
wondering if they're gonna have a moment like that
at the end of the moon knight series where like
we see the origin story through the first couple
of episodes like okay he was dying made this pact
with him gave him his powers but then at the end
of the series maybe they'll have a moment where
his seemingly dies but then has like a jon snow
game of thrones moment where he just sits back
up alive again as if kanchu has resurrected him
again in some kind of post-credit scene tag at
the end where it says moon knight will return
because we do know that he's coming back like he
is supposed to cross over with the avengers i've
already talked about his connection with werewolf
by night in blade we're going to be seeing both
of those characters again later this year during
the marvel halloween special that they're doing
that special episode for werewolf by night so
maybe they'll also be a post-credits scene sort
of setting that up i'm not expecting werewolf by
night to really show up in a big way to like the
very end of the moon knight series he might just
wind up being one of the post-credits scenes but
the way they've been talking about the series it
is a little bit like indiana jones in fight club
because of all the egyptian mythology the egyptian
history all these artifacts the egyptian gods the
pantheon in the fight club references because of
the multiple personalities like the whole idea
during fight club is that you see tyler durden in
the movie treats him for at least most the movie
as if he's a completely separate person until
the end where you find out that he was just
an alternate personality of edward norton's main
character who eventually confronts him and defeats
him even though it was all taking place in his
mind say it because we're the same person that's
right so we'll see if there's a similar type of
twist during the moon knight series but i don't
think that marvel is trying to literally borrow
that much from fight club i think it's just some
of the surface elements some of the aesthetics
i've already talked about some of the other
footage in my other trailer videos so i'm not
going to cover that stuff again but if there are
any other easter eggs or questions you have about
moon knight just write them in the comments below
episodes are dropping march 30th i'll be doing
videos for all the episodes just like i do for
all the other marvel disney plus series so make
sure you enable alerts for your channel so you
don't miss any of those there's been a couple more
spider man no way home deleted scenes that have
surfaced so i will do videos for those in the next
couple of days too everyone click here for that
new spider-man no way home deleted scenes video
and click here for my brand new marvel daredevil
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!